today what I want to share with you is
something that happened to me actually
around four weeks ago it happened I
words were said to me but I never
thought I would ever hear said to my
face by another human being and those
words they shattered my heart and at the
same time they filled it with so much
hope and the whole experience renewed my
commitment to the idea that I came to
share with you today
you see I tell everyone but I am a
haunted person what haunts me is the
impossible stories story as the story of
the story of the story of young people
my people people like me dying out there
in the ocean right now laying at the
bottom of the ocean serving as fish food
do you really think that's the best we
can do to serve as fish food and for
those of them who are trying to migrate
to Europe because that's what it is all
about we're trying to migrate here to
find a job going through Libya do you
know what happens to us when we're
trying to cross the Libyan retract over
there well we've been sold as slaves for
300 dollars maybe sometimes 500 dollars
sometimes I hear stories of bodies that
fall off an airplane somebody hid in the
landing year of a plane or in the cargo
section of the plane and when you find
them throw them to death
wouldn't you be haunted if like me from
the moment you were a little girl you
hear these stories and they keep
repeating themselves over and over and
over
wouldn't you be haunted that's my case
and at the same time you know as my
people are dying my culture is also
dying there I said it
because you know we have
entirely which means that anything that
comes from us is not good enough but you
know in my situation and because I was
raised to criticize by creating its
michelangelo's my father said do not
come to me with problems unless you
thought of a couple alternatives they
don't have to be white but I just want
to know what you thought of something so
I have this attitude in life something
is wrong
find a way to fix it and that's why I
started businesses what I start but is
usually consumer brands but have
embedded in them the very best of my
African culture and what I do is it's
all packaged 21st century world class
standard and I bring that to one of the
most sophisticated markets in the in the
United's in the world which is the u.s.
first company was a beverage company
second one is a skincare company third
one is launching next month and we all
have that in common so why are we
sleeping they're leaving because they
have no jobs believe me because where
they are there is no jobs so but poverty
but really striking them is at the cause
root cause of why we're leaving now why
are people poor people are poor because
I have no money you have no money
because you have no source of income and
for most of us what is a source of
income for most of us what is our source
of income what is it tell me
jobs thank you where do jobs come from
come from where business says thank you
now if jobs is what fixes poverty and
jobs come from businesses don't you
think especially come from small and
medium-sized enterprises SMEs then don't
you think maybe for a second but we
should focus on making it easy for a
small business person to start and run
their business don't you think that it
makes sense why is it that when I look
at the Doing Business Index ranking of a
World Bank that ranks every country in
the world as in terms of how is your
holidays you start a company you tell me
why African countries all 50 of them are
basically at the bottom of that list
that's why we're poor we're poor because
it is literally impossible to do
businesses in these countries of ours
and I only tell you exactly what it
means on the ground someone like me you
know I have a manufacturing facility in
Senegal did you know that for all my raw
material that I can't find in the
country I have to pay a forty five
percent tariff on everything that comes
in forty five percent tariffs do you
know that even to look for fine
cardboards to ship my finished products
to the US i can't find new finished
cardboards impossible why because those
guys are not gonna come here to start
their business but you know buddy
Jupiter's because it makes no sense
either so right now I have to mobilize
$3,000 worth of cardboards in my
warehouse so that I can have cardboard
and by the way they won't arrive for
another five weeks the fact that we are
stifled with the most nonsense laws out
there that's why we can't run business
that is a swimming through molasses so
today today so what can you do about
that you know I told you today but
someone said to me words that marked me
the words where because I explained the
same thing to my employees in Senegal
and one of them started crying her name
is Yahara she started crying
and I said why you crying she said me
I'm crying because I never I had come to
believe always seeing as represented as
poor people I had come to believe that
maybe yes maybe we are inferior because
otherwise how do you explain that we're
always in the begging situation that's
what brought my heart but at the same
time that you said that because of how
explain just what I explained to you she
said but now I know but I am NOT the
problem it is my environment in which I
live that's my problem I said yes and
that's what gave me hope that once
people get it they now change her
outlook on life here what are some of
the solutions then if jobs is a solution
and we need a good dr. Sigman but we
should be simplifying the business
environment of all of these countries
don't you think and along with you I
would like for all of your friends from
the other 50 countries that are the
bottom of my list to do the same thing
you do that we do the rest of the job
I'm doing my part of the game what are
you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
and as for you everybody here in this
room I leave you with two marching
orders get in the game and the way you
get in it is educate yourself build
awareness around yourself around use
your self and then also advocate for a
government solutions he said Oh
corruption how do we fight corruption
well as a matter of fact I'm here to
tell you that yes you can do it by the
stroke of a pen you do not need anyone
to tell you when and how to do that it
is one thing actually but you don't need
to wait for anyone to do so do it
otherwise don't come and tell me that
you want to fix corruption you and your
other fifty friends from the other 50
countries that are bottom of that list
that's how you fight corruption because
corruption happens if you were only
charging me 5% to get my stuff in the
country my raw material instead of a
forty five percent do you really think
that I would have to go and pay a bribe
that's what breeds corruption bad law
assets of horrible nonsense laws
you want to fight corruption that's what
you do and again remember I told you you
don't need to wait for anyone you can do
that by yourself unless you're telling
me that maybe you have no sovereignty
and then that's a whole nother problem
isn't it okay so so from here on I have
simple words for our leaders this will
this can go two ways it can go a nasty
way because we have hundreds of millions
of young people coming to life right now
here and if you do not if they don't
have an outlet in life they are gonna go
for a revolution they're gonna go for
violence and none of that none of us
wants that none none of us so that's one
way can go of a second way can go is
always happens peacefully productively
and everything is good and you do what
you need to do you get out of my way you
let people like me do our job we create
all the jobs we need and then everybody
Africa becomes this very prosperous
country that is designed to it should
have been for a long time it happens
like that everybody's happy we move on
with our lives can happen two ways pick
violence or you pick the calm productive
way I want a contradictory way none of
us should ever ever even try to think
about what else could happen if we don't
go there
so please and the time has come this
type of picture prosperity happiness
human flourishing that's what I see if
we do our job thank you
[Applause]
[Music]